よっし
やりますがありますがありますか
作例てあーおれ外れ砂糖高い
ウソでしょ
場でもなっていない
結構重大な
場面でねまず歴史なんこれでも重大ハス夜中にこんにちははじめ社長と
匠副社長と馬崎取締役です
はい
今日は
まあ大事なコックスです
とっても大事な黒子だと思います
まあこの2人
高見工藤さきがいると思うんですけど
笑ってはいるんですけども
あのーまあ
匠が去年夫に戻ってきてくれて
マサキが
今年のもうそれだねもうセグ
大学院が卒業ということなんですけども
今年の春までに
2人とも
僕の
なんだよね
なった今年のこれまでに
我々は
01:00
改ざんという理由になります
どっか話していけばいいんだろ
だからなんか日目ますかそんな感じ
最初はグーじゃんけん分
うんどうせ俺からどうですね
えっとこの
3月
で一応大学院を
終了するということで
えっと
大学入ってからほんとモール丸6年ぐらい
翌年だでだねぇ
なんでやばいいね大学4年と大学院にね
あわせて6年間一緒に土が出たりとか
してやってきたんですけどこの大学院を卒業する
タイミングで
とりあえず一区切りということで
来年と4月からはえっと長野の方に
もどって
向こうでとりあえず1年
先生を
中学校の
音楽の先生を
やります
今までずっと学生だったし
まあこういう youtube ウェイ
関連のことしか全然や
出ないので例年は働いてまたが来年度1年間働いた後っていうのがまだ決まってないの
で
まあどうなるかは全然まだ分からないですけど一区切りということで
この
夏で
卒業二行種を卒業します
お疲れした
これ移動だけでもなんだろうなぁ
マサキは本当に
youtube や
てきても約6年の分年約6年やってきて
まあ集5
最初から最後まで
常に僕のことを見てきた
唯一の1人だもんねね
本当に
その彼がいなくなるっていうのは結構
低回数僕の中でも
でもこれは
彼が決めたことなので
皆さんも是非
応援してあげて欲しいと思っております
100円に関してはつけると2人の武智年+かです
あの去年匠が帰ってきて一緒に行こう
夏からかな夏前から一緒にやってきたんですけども
まあそんな悪い意味に捉えてほしくないです
マネーミュートがあっても助けないんですけどもまぁ良くも破れても
お互いにちょっとやりたいことというか
何て言えばいいのなんて弱いんだろうねぇ
や問屋等ありの関係をお互いにすごいやりにくかったよ
なんかと友達がパンツ米大学の同じ出す仲良く一緒に行ってきたんで
このままこう一緒に働くと結局
オイラが最初に
入って後から健美が切ったわけだから
このへんな臓器関係なんだけど実際はを
友達だからそこで何か変な音
このすれちがうというかものでロールで仕事をしてねそこで普通に
まあ生活しててその追加通してい
はじめ本関わりがあってそれは大学時代も同じで大学の6月とか大学の他の
コミュニティも保ちつつはじめと一緒にいるし頑張ってっていうお互いにお互いの軸が
こうある状態でかかってたからこそ日々
感じお味を出せ2のかなってところがこの夏以降は
は完全にはじめがいてその
下に巻くこれ方言動画でリーチを下にいることに変わりはないけどし計画に関する
ところまで
やと言う母と雇われるクハの関係に変わってきてお互いにやっぱり友達としてやってき
たところからその
雇う雇われるって関係が入ってくるとどうしてもぎくしゃくしてきちゃっててるん
学校今までとは違った感じになってきてたなっていうのはあ
で
そこもお互いてちょっと話し合った結果別々の
道に
ということになりますとはじめの必要とするときはもちろん全部手伝いに行くし
まあ一例が必要とか9仕掛けられやってほしいというのがあればもう騙されても行くの
でそこは変わらないんだけどどっちにしろ映像にかかっていく
中国に
入ってくれるちっちゃく
かねこっちに
こっちの的に選んだの僕なんでまぁ
要約すると
春までに
解散してしまいますチェック没
なんつってっあのひとつみなさんに勘違いしてますけどいいのはですねんから
ここ3人がギクシャクしたとか抜かす技研かするとそういうわけでは全くないので
その時は感じがしないで頂きたいところでございます
ここからそれぞれ口ということで
そうだんだろうねぇ
今度は館内に目先のことないねひょっとしたら1年後にパターン
うーんかもしれないかも撮ったりどこかでつながったりそれかもしんないし
で普通に
次の音生むのイベントでこれ最前列で何かな
これかわかんないしとりあえずラインでまま先取ることはあんまりないのかもしれない
んですね
もう
たとえ人はまた別の東京だかなーんかもしれないんですけど
感じでー
これだけは皆さんに言っておきたいと思います違う思いました
感じかなはい本当に
仲良しだからねまあ本当にすごい大本当に普通にプライベートとして
あればいいなって感じなんですよねぇ
これ本当にはじめ寒波に解散だよねだねぇ
お店ねぇちょっと寂しい
程度なぁ
別れもあれば出会いもある
春ということで員ともうちょっとベクトルは違うんですけどもそれぞれまたいろんな
分野で活躍できるように頑張っていきたいと思います性のあるという
me
あっひっ